[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 4 avril la
mobilité de demain se prépare dans les
yvelines sur le camp de satory à
versailles et l'institut vd comme
travaille actuellement sur une trentaine
de projets et des véhicules électriques
ou encore autonome toutes ces années de
recherches étaient présentés ce matin
devant la presse entretien
la cybersécurité une thématique devenu
aujourd'hui incontournable
un an après la taxe mondiale aux virus
ouanna cry le lycée militaire de saint
cyr l'école a inauguré officiellement
aujourd'hui son bts cyberdéfense une
formation ouverte en septembre dernier
enfin avec les jours qui se rallonger
qui se réchauffe les sorties en plein
air reviennent pour vous donner quelques
idées l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines organise ses portes ouvertes
le week end prochain
on en parle avec notre invité à 400
kilomètres de bouchons cumulés ce matin
en ile-de-france conséquences de la
grève dans les transports en commun un
mouvement perlé des cheminots de trois
mois contre la réforme ferroviaire
après deux jours de galère un quasi
retour à la normale est prévu dans la
journée de demain jeudi
en moyenne 3 trains sur 4 sur l'ensemble
des trains en ile-de-france prochaine
grève à partir de dimanche s'est
retrouvé tous les horaires de vos trains
sur le site du transilien
l information est unique en france et en
europe depuis la rentrée de septembre le
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
propose un tout nouveau bts un cursus en
cyberdéfense suivi déjà par une
promotion de 32 élèves
le bts a été inauguré officiellement ce
mercredi matin mickaël millero étaient
sur place
une première en france l'école militaire
de saint cyr l'école est inauguré ce
mercredi 4 avril locaux du bts
cyberdéfense une formation créée en
septembre dernier qui a pour objectif de
former des experts en informatique pour
protéger des données
c'est une grande fierté parce que c'est
une formation très très innovante qui
s'est bâti en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale et qui a réussi à
produire une formation très spécifique
qui n'a d'équivalent nulle part ailleurs
pour former ses 32 à coeur en uniforme
un programme spécifique a été imaginé on
fait beaucoup d'informatique de la
programmation du réseau un enseignement
spécifique en physique mais également de
la culture générale des langues est une
formation une initiation aux techniques
et à l'organisation de la cybersécurité
ce cursus pourrait leur permettre
d'accéder à l'école de formation des
sous-officiers de l'armée de terre ou
aux services de renseignement du
ministère des armées
la plupart du monde et interconnectés
par l'information par les l'ordinateur
l'informatique donc je pense que c'est
clairement le futur c'est le plus
important aujourd'hui
la section a déjà reçu près de 800
candidatures pour la rentrée 2010 8 pour
seulement 30 de places
le lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
qui est depuis quelques jours sous le
feu des polémiques depuis les
révélations le 23 mars dernier de nos
confrères de libération des faits
sexistes et d'humiliation d'un groupe
d'élèves masculin est d'une classe
préparatoire à l'encontre d'étudiantes
de l'établissement alain godon le
proviseur du lycée militaire réagi pour
la première fois sur ces possibles
dérives misogyne c'est une information
tv 78 au micro de michael et demi
d'euros c'est une polémique qui est née
de l'identification de quelques élèves
dans une classe très particulière de
notre établissement
le phénomène donc existe il n'est pas
niable mais il est extrêmement marginale
et
absolument pas ne s'étant absolument pas
l'ensemble des formations de
l'établissement ces phénomènes sont
identifiés les personnes sont
identifiées et les
les incidents sont traités actuellement
et déboucheront sur des sanctions à
l'actualité de ce mercredi a marqué
encore par les difficultés dans les
transports en commun ou vous en parlais
tout à l'heure deuxième jour de grève
pour les cheminots avant une nouvelle
mobilisation dès dimanche pendant que la
réforme de la sncf fait débat l institut
vd comme à satory travail lui sur le
véhicule du futur qu'il soit électrique
autonome
une trentaine de projets sont
actuellement en cours nicolas
kirillovitch et patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est donc la cinquième année d'activité
pour vd comme l'institut ici qui est
basé à satory à cinq années de
recherches pour le véhicule du futur le
véhicule électrique le véhicule autonome
aussi la mobilité de demain 5 ans
l'occasion de faire le bilan avec le
président rémi bastien cinq ans quel
regard vous vous portez sur ces cinq ans
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de votre
bilan j'imagine j'imagine que oui
forcément
bonjour alors très satisfait parce que
on le voit tout au long de cette journée
les recherches ont été conduites dans
les quatre dernières années
produisent des tas de résultats je pense
que ce qui est souvent le plus connu
c'est la mobilité un véhicule autonome
parce que c'est très à la mode mais on
va plus loin que le simple véhicule
l'institut regarde comment l'exploiter
pour faire une mobilité partagée qu'on
peut commander le véhicule électrique
comme vous l'avez signalé donc est
incontournable sur la durée pour les
questions de co2 pour la qualité de
l'air donc là dans l'institut on a
développé plein de briques qui vont
accélérer le développement de véhicules
électriques
aujourd'hui si j'ai bien compris bien
cerner vos projets vous travaillez sur
une trentaine de projets
mine de rien tout le monde s'arrête vous
le disiez sur le véhicule autonome et la
priorité c'est le véhicule électrique
concrètement où en sont vos recherches
est ce qu'on va avoir un véhicule vd
comme bientôt sur la route pour aller
chercher le pain pour partir en vacances
alors on va surtout avoir nos membres
qui vont tirer profit de tout ce qu'on
développe ici puisque dans les membres
et les deux constructeurs français alors
en ça étonne toujours les gens de voir
que deux concurrents frontaux se met
dans ce même institut
et ça ça marche et donc ce que fait bd
comme vous verrez pas de marques td com
et vous verrez des retombées
dans les années qui viennent y compris
déjà je pense cette année dans les
gammes des deux constructeurs
merci à rémy bastien et donc vous allez
le voir ici beaucoup de projets sont en
cours c'est assez impressionnant on va
vous montrer notamment qu'elle peut-être
l'interaction entre un véhicule autonome
et un piéton et on va vous montrer aussi
quelques-uns des projets de recherche
assez marquante dans ses laboratoires et
parmi ces projets de recherche ici avait
des comme il ya les recherches sur la
chaleur au sein de l'habitacle
comment réduire cette température ou
l'art est aussi pour ensuite consommer
moins d'énergie on encore sur cette
volonté éco-responsable consommer moins
d'énergie on va à poser la question
justement un haut responsable du projet
rock el khoury bonjour expliquez-nous un
peu votre projet de recherche en quoi il
consiste dans notre projet auxiliaires
très basse consommation
on se focalise donc sur la consommation
des auxiliaires c'est tous les organes
qui ne servent pas à propulser le
véhicule sur ces auxiliaires l'alleud
le conditionnement thermique de la
cabine donc le chauffage et la clim
c'est le principal contributeur donc sûr
quand on roule en ville dans une
température un peu extrêmes on peut
aller jusqu à consommer plus d'énergie
pour chauffer l'habitacle que pour
propulser le véhicule sur les véhicules
électriques c'est très très très
important sur l'autonomie parce qu'on
n'a pas de perte à l'extérieur donc on
est obligé de venir puiser sur l'énergie
de la batterie pour réchauffer la cabine
et comme on peut voir ici sur un cycle
de roulage urbain de la renault zoé 41
kilowattheure à 20 degrés on est à 360
kilomètres et quand on met la clim
à moins 15 on peint on peut aller à 180
km d'autonomie
ce qu'on essaie de faire dans ce projet
c'est réduire l'impact de la gestion
thermique de la cabine sur la
consommation énergétique du véhicule
électrique et sur son autonomie tout en
améliorant et ne pas descendre dégradé
le confort thermique des occupants ce
que le but quand même c'est pas de
vendre des véhicules et des doudounes
pour permettre le chauffage
[Musique]
l'un des grands enjeux de dvd comme ici
à satory c'est d'imaginer le véhicule du
futur et ce véhicule sera forcément
autonome et il faudra donc réfléchir à
l'interaction avec les piétons c'est le
projet sur lequel travaille cette
voiture là précisément cette voiture
renault
nous allons poser des questions aux
chercheurs du projet responsable du
projet et voir une démonstration pour
voir comment cette voiture voit les
piétons pour les éviter et les laisser
passer tout de suite
une
[Musique]
jo le guen n est donc l'un des
responsables de ce projet qui vise à à
voir comment la voiture peu à la voiture
autonome peut interagir avec les piétons
sur la route
jean-louis onen expliqué nous un peu
comment comment marche ce projet comment
ça fonctionne concrètement comment la
voiture détecte le piéton au bord au
bord de la route
donc en fait la voiture autonome va
utiliser les caméras un système de lidar
et de radars pour détecter le piéton
donc nous serons on est en train de
faire c'est dans ce projet là c'est
d'apprendre à la voiture d'estimé
l'intention du piéton donc une fois que
le piéton elle est détectée en fait la
voiture va essayer de voir à ce que le
piéton va s'arrêter au bord de la route
à ce qu il est en attente est ce qu'il a
engagé pour traverser parce qu'il
traverse
afin de prendre une décision ce qui veut
dire que aujourd'hui vous entraîner la
voiture vous entraîner à la faire
réfléchir en quelque sorte oui bien sûr
c'est ça on nous on apprend en fait à la
voiture de détecter la posture des
piétons et d'interpréter la posture de
piétons donc pour cela en fait on fait
des tests et à la fin de ces tests ont
fait des traitements pour apprendre la
voiture de
de faire tout ça alors là on a vu on a
vu un exemple de ce projet on a vu le
piéton qui était au bord de la route la
voiture qui s'est arrêtée pour laisser
traverser ça c'est combien d'années deux
mois de travail pour réussir déjà à
faire ça en phase de test ici avait des
comme donc ce projet a débuté il ya un
an et demi de coûts maintenant il nous
reste encore beaucoup de temps pour pour
arriver à détecter piétons dans toutes
les conditions possibles nous on veut
passer de piétons à la trottinette avec
les enfants en fait les parents avec les
enfants et tout ça donc ça serait dans
un an ou deux
[Musique]
et ce matin plusieurs présidents de
départements étaient en visite justement
avait des comme à satory dont celui des
yvelines pierre bédier l occasion et
d'évoquer avec lui la polémique du
moment avec versailles et son maire
françois de mazières
dans les colonnes du parisien lady lay
divers droite estime que sa ville est
mise de côté par le département un
traitement en déloyale qui fait suite
selon lui ont reçu de versailles de
travailler avec les yvelines pour
l'aménagement d'un nouveau quartier le
département aurait notamment répression
retirer une subvention de 18000 euros à
la cité royale des propos contré par
pierre bédier il assure qu' aucune
commune n'est blacklisté écoutez le au
micro de nicolas kirillovitch la ville
de versailles n'a jamais été ostracisé
nous avons une vraie divergence de fond
avec le maire de versailles
oui c'est vrai et qui fait que nous
n'accompagnons pas sa politique puisque
nous pensons qu'elle n'est pas bonne
dans la ville de versailles et les
collaborateurs de pierre bédier
envisagerait de faire appel devant la
justice en cas de diffamation à son
encontre
vous avez déjà forcément entendu ce nom
linkedin un réseau social professionnel
qui met en avant à les parcours et
compétences de sujets de chacun avec 14
millions de français en sont aujourd'hui
membres à l'hôtel le louis à versailles
la semaine dernière un événement a mise
en relation les utilisateurs de la ville
et des alentours le linkedin locale une
initiative au niveau mondial un montage
signé sandrine fontaine discuter
réseauter et échanger des cartes de
visite dans une ambiance décontractée
c'est l'esprit des linkedin locale un
concept né dans les pays anglophones
pour faciliter les rencontres et
développer les opportunités
professionnelles permettre à leurs
communautés de se rencontrer en flammes
ce qu'on se rend compte que c'est des
réseaux qui sont très basses at on a
parfois connecte à des centaines voire
des milliers de personnes et c'était
connexion qu'on n'exploite pas donc le
but c'est justement de permettre
d'activer sur réseau une dizaine de
villes en france adhère déjà au
mouvement paris nice lyon et maintenant
versailles le premier linkedin locales
dont la ville a été organisée mardi 27
mars à l'hôtel le louis plus de 50
personnes habitant ou exerçant dans la
cité royale et ses alentours ont
participé à la soie je me bats souvent
contre versailles cette belle endormie
or on est une ville dynamique avec une
population souvent active des profils
professionnels totalement différent et
je pensais que linky pour être un liant
entre les différentes personnes et
c'était vraiment l'occasion d'être
ensemble au delà du simple profil
linkedin chefs d'entreprise drh
communicants ou encore auto
entrepreneurs les profils présents à ce
premier linkedin local versaillais
étaient variés c'est toujours
intéressant de pouvoir rencontrer
d'autres entrepreneurs et donc d'élargir
notre notre réseau c'est étonnant les
profils
roulette nos différents mais tu peux
apporter après
pourquoi pas
du business ou des nouvelles de parti
vite et on se retrouve beaucoup de
versailles et et c'est très agréable
on se connaît parfois de vue et c'est
agréable pour échanger un petit peu un
nouveau linkedin local est d'ores et
déjà programmée à versailles le mardi 26
juin juste après le match de coupe du
monde de football france danemark on
reste à versailles avec ce rendez vous
incontournable à l'arrivée du printemps
les fontaines du château reprenne vie
les grandes eaux musicales rejaillissent
dans les jardins mélanie poquet sur des
images de michael et demi d'euros unique
et féerique majestueux ferme bio l'os
mais elles font toujours briller les
yeux ces grandes eaux du château de
versailles depuis plus de 350 ans les
600 jeux d'eau débute au printemps un
ballet majestueux préparé par les treize
fontenay
[Musique]
c'est toujours la même émotion d'offrir
à bas le travail de l'hiver où tout a
été entretenue réparé pour que la d2 18
commence avec de belles zoé et va durer
toute la saison aux sons de jean
baptiste lully jean philippe rameau et
marc antoine charpentier 55 fontaines et
bassins s'anime
parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin de neptune
[Musique]
le bassin neptune est un bassin qui est
le plus vaste avec son système de
fontanes ancien de tout le château est
un des plus vastes d'europe avec près de
150 mètres entre guillemets de dénivelé
de fond de dérouler de fontaine par
contre comme il consomme énormément
d'eau il ne peut être mise en doute très
rarement
donc on a trouvé un système automatisé
dans le centre du bassin là où il n'y a
pas de fontaine ancienne pour proposer
au public à cet endroit une activité
hydraulique qui ne soit pas celle de la
présidentielle
avec plus de 100 représentations les
grandes eaux et jardins musicaux sont
une invitation à la promenade dans les
pas du roi soleil un instant suspendu
qui attire chaque année près de 12000
visiteurs par jour
à saint quentin en yvelines depuis le 31
mars et la sixième édition de baby âge
un événement est dédié aux tout petits
dans le réseau des médiathèques
spectacle à tables rondes ateliers
autour de tapis sonore et sensorielle
l'offre est variée pour émerveiller
présentation au micro d'aurélie rose et
marion de tac c'est un focus sur l'album
et le tout petit et cette année on va
partir dans le thème objectif image donc
voila tout va tourner tous nos
spectacles nous animations nos ateliers
vont tourner autour de l'image fixe et
de l'image animée
c'est un public pour la littérature pour
les albums pour les histoires c'est des
enfants qui apprécient les spectacles
etc des enfants qui rentrent très
facilement dans le monde imaginaire
l inscription est obligatoire toute la
programmation est à retrouver sur le
site internet des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
dépêchez-vous cet événement prend fin le
14 avril
peinture sculpture photographie une
sélection d'oeuvres différentes à
découvrir à la salle d'exposition à
guyancourt leur point commun elles se
sont toutes des oeuvres d'artistes du
territoire choisi par un jury de
professionnels art à l'enm est à
l'honneur les talents locaux découverte
avec camille lambert et nicolas landry
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose d'un peu
apocalyptique où les gens les routes
vont nulle part j'avais envie d'un peu
d'exprimer sa une société où il reste
quelques éléments de marketing avec des
marques qui sont un peu on me présente
vous tout est un peu ça le tout est un
peu délavé
comme s'ils s'étaient passé quelque
chose mais les gens continuent leur vie
dans cette ville c'est un petit peu ce
que je voulais a présenté avec beaucoup
d'influencé bien sûr de science fiction
de films futuristes de divers dystopie
d'où le nom de l'oeuvre dystopia une
ville futuriste créé à partir de cartons
de circuits imprimés ou de plastique un
univers foisonnant imaginé par kg sommes
plusieurs mois de travail pour cet
habitant de guyancourt avec art talent
la ville lui donne l'opportunité
d'exposer avec d'autres artistes du
territoire
c'est notre troisième édition c'est un
concours d'art en direction des artistes
locaux professionnels et bien sûr
amateurs c'est vraiment divers
complètement toutes les esthétiques donc
à la sculpture la peinture la
photographie un mélange de techniques et
d'émotion des paysages épurés du désert
de l'invité d'honneur francis tac aux
créatures surréalistes d'arnaud shoot
c'est chamlal c'est une
photo fait à la base de farine qui
ensuite sur un portrait farine je le met
en mode miroir et on obtient une ce que
j'appelle des bestioles je veux que
chacun puisse partir un petit peu là où
il a envie d'aller avec cette bestiole
là je l'imaginé quelques barreaux
imaginez juste de l'imaginer savoir ce
qu'elle représente une sélection
d'oeuvres à découvrir jusqu'au 29 avril
différents ateliers rencontres avec les
artistes sont prévues tout le mois un
invité marc a rejoint en plateau vincent
couteau bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
du pôle événementiel communication à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines ils dosent wazir qui accueille
qui organise ce week end à ses portes
ouvertes ça s'appelle tous à lille ça se
déroule donc samedi 7 et dimanche 8
avril
on va parler du programme dans un
instant déjà peut-être un mot de
présentation sur l'île de loisirs pour
ceux qui ne la connaissent pas elle
s'étend sur 6 hectares autour d'un grand
plan d'eau sur six ans et d'un 600 ha
oui c'est la perte est important de le
préciser oui effectivement 600 hectares
de kate moss est là alors c'est la plus
grande et la plus belle île de loisirs
d'île de france 600 hectares de deux
pleine nature et que le plus grand plan
d'eau d'île de france également d'accord
et vous pouvez trouver toutes sortes
d'activités pour tous depuis le plus
jeune âge jusqu'aux l'âge de plus
avancée pour les sportifs ou les
amoureux de la nature
pour les amateurs de sensations fortes
en avant pour tout le monde alors là on
est au début du printemps et à l'été qui
va suivre on est au tout début de la
grande période la grande saison pour
lille de loisirs mois exactement là
vraiment mois d'avril c'est le lancement
de la saison c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
positionne ce week-end à ce moment-là à
ses rangs pour inviter tous les saint
quentinois les yvelines aux mêmes les
les franciliens à venir découvrir cet
espace là venir découvrir les activités
puisque on s'est rendu compte que les
saint quentinois notamment connaissent
l'île des loisirs mais finalement ils ne
se rendent pas compte du panel
d'activités qu'on peut qu'on pouvait
faire ceci pour les inviter à koné l'île
de loisirs on l'appelle même
d'ailleurs de loisirs base de loisirs se
son ancien nom les activités sur place
en revanche toute l'étendue d'activité
on la connaît pas forcément ça oui plus
de plus de 25 activités qui sont
proposées
ouverte tous les jours donc notamment
pendant les vacances scolaires
c'est vrai que je conçois une entreprise
et qu'on va faire un team building ou un
séminaire où qu'on soit un groupe
scolaire ou qu'on soit en particulier
qu'on va faire un footing ou de visiter
la réserve naturelle vraiment il ya des
détails activités à découvrir tous les
jours
alors c'est la deuxième édition de tous
à lille ça avait bien marché l'année
dernière c'est pour ça qu'on leur
proposait cette année tout à fait ça a
très bien fonctionné sur un week-end où
on n'a pas une fréquentation trop
massive puisqu'on sait que sur le très
beau week-end deux mois de mai et juin
il doit dire change un peu de visages d
accueil vraiment énormément de monde là
on encore finalement une fréquentation
tout toute relative qui nous permet
justement d'organiser ce genre de
week-end
et puis d'inviter les usagers à venir
découvrir ce site dans un climat de
quiétude
alors pourquoi organisé ses portes
ouvertes quel message qui n'en voulait
faire passer là sur ces deux jours deux
journées portes ouvertes alors le
message c'est vraiment venez découvrir
l'ensemble des activités de loisirs
venez aussi découvrir le village ryder
cup parce qu'on a la chance d'accueillir
le village ryder cup sur ce week end là
et et puis pourquoi pas aller voir
régulièrement sur sur le site un des
deux leaders wazir le compte facebook de
l'île des loisirs ce qui s'affiche
actuellement ou à le site internet en
tout cas exactement parce que c'est
vraiment sur ces dispositifs là qu'on
arrive à mettre de l'information sinon
on communique peu en dehors de l'île des
loisirs vraiment j'incite tous les
usagers à se rendre régulièrement sur
ces sites là pour voir tout ce qui s'y
fait alors parlons du programme il est
diversifié variés d'abord un village
ryder cup ryder cup pardon je vais y
arriver on on va en dire deux mots alors
le village ryder cup forcément à
quelques mois maintenant de ce grand
événement qui va arriver à saint quentin
en yvelines en septembre
en septembre on est tout à fait un
événement à ne pas louper mais qu'on ne
pourra pas louper de toute façon vu
l'ampleur de l'événement
donc
la fédération de française de golf et la
côte et d'agglomération un discours
beaucoup plus léché club bien sûr sur
l'accès au golfe et finalement c'est une
activité qui a beaucoup plus accessible
qu'il n'y paraît en ce moment on a même
des portes ouvertes au golf blue green
et loire loisirs donc là aussi il faut
pas hésiter à s'inscrire c'est vraiment
une super activités à découvrir et puis
là il y aura tous les ateliers autour de
la ryder cup avec réalité virtuelle pour
découvrir les parcours du golf national
initiation au golf etc ça sera samedi et
dimanche de 14h à 18h ya aussi le skate
park qui est proposé pendant ces les
portes sont ouvertes
oui exactement dans l'ancienne piscine à
vagues qui est devenu aujourd'hui un
espace événementiel de skype par qui
nous a rejoint l'an dernier et qui
propose une multitude d'activités hyper
novatrices comme du pilotage de drones
et là en l'occurrence il ya sky par
quelques le premier club depuis otage de
drones de reis
mais alors course de saint quentin en
yvelines donc il y aura des
démonstrations aussi de course c'est
vraiment hyper impressionnant avec des
petits modules qui vont jusqu'à 130
kilomètres heure et puis un parcours de
softball qui est aussi une des
nouveautés de cette année proposé par
skypark un troisième espace ouvert pour
ses portes ouvertes samedi et dimanche
de 14h à 18h le sky équitation oui tout
à fait ce sera même toute la journée il
propose alors ils organisent un concours
complet
donc c'est vraiment très impressionnant
à voir vraiment il n'ya plus de 200
participants
donc là aussi ça peut être bien la
partie baptêmes poneys et balades nature
qui seront ouvertes donc là on ouvre des
créneaux spécifiques sur la base nature
à cheval pour tous niveaux et
possibilité d'aller voir justement le
concours complet se dérouler et puis
voir un peu de tout les toutes les
épreuves qui peuvent proposer une
équitation
on retrouve bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site de l'île de
loisirs 50 ans neeve et une dernière
question il nous reste un peu moins
d'une minute quels sont vos espérances
là avec ce début de saison printemps été
2010 8 quelles sont les les espérances
pour lille de loisirs comme à l'image de
notre nouvelle activité de benji
injection un bon décollage
pour le mois d'avril et puis a vraiment
une très belle saison avril mai juin
surtout puis évidemment un bel été pour
proposer cette part que la tous les
saint quentinois
merci vincent couteau d'avoir été avec
nous merci au responsable du pôle
événementiel et communication à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
avant de se quitter c'est une tradition
chaque année pendant le week-end de
pâques le tournoi international lucien
palace était organisée par le sky rugby
il s'est tenu samedi et dimanche à
elancourt vingt-et-une équipes en lice
répartis en trois catégories moins de 10
moins de 12 et moins de 14 ans et les
clubs venus de toute la france mais
aussi à d'irlande et d'allemagne propos
recueillis par nicolas landry
oui tout s'est bien passé
le tournoi a été bien organisée le club
a été très accueillant
si on obtient plus de victoires on sera
encore plus content je trouve ça sympa
on compte deux équipes des yvelines ou
étrangères comme la cette année des
allemands c'est pas pareil dans une
équipe sur le terrain qui parle pas
talent il joue pas de la même façon ne
fait pas la même chose et puis on s'est
super bien de voir arriver des jeunes
d'autres pays de voir qu'ils s'éclatent
sur un sur un plateau comme ça qu'ils
sont contents de voir les installations
les belles d'installation d'elancourt de
voir la culture française le repas
sympathique entre dirigeants et tout
s'annonce assez sympa et ce tournoi a
été remporté par le club de maisons
laffitte poissy saint germain pour la
catégorie des moins de 14 ans plaisir
pour les moins de 12 ans et un ex-aequo
pour les moins de 10 ans entre plaisir
et pontault combault
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci
de l'avoir suivi une édition à revoir
bien sûr sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]